so we talked about this but didn't use
the word non-dualism and many people in
the non-dualist community would say that
love is fundamental that Consciousness
is fundamental but love is too and
somehow those are the same or somehow
love is more fundamental than
Consciousness okay
explain to someone as confused as myself
what you make of that how does that make
sense how can love be fundamental What
is love
Bernardo if you don't mind well I I I
never said that love is fundamental no
I'm not saying you did it I apologize if
I said that I'm saying some non-dualists
I'm sure you've heard that you didn't
say that I'm just I'm just emphasizing
it for for clarity and lack of ambiguity
I think love is a particular pattern of
excitation of Consciousness fear is
another so if love is fundamental so is
fear
um and so is I don't know delight and
and any any other emotion so from that
perspective I think it is subjectivity
that is fundamental not to the
particular excitation of subjectivity
that we describe with words such as love
fear and all the other emotions
um so I think empirically if I if I look
at nature
I don't see compelling reason to think
that love is somehow
more
primordial or more fundamental than fear
than than evil because you see this
stuff all around the nature I mean
animals are killing each other slowly
and painfully so they can survive it's a
bloodbath volcanoes erupt and millions
of animals are killed in very painful
circumstances it's not a pretty picture
so I I don't particularly
see a reason to prioritize
love over over anything else I mean
Dante wrote about the love that moves
the sun and the other stars suggesting
that you know what what we see as stars
is
um is the representation of love the
external appearance of love and that
stars in and of themselves
experience themselves as an outpouring
of love that may be but then black holes
are the opposite right because instead
of irradiating they suck everything in
and I see no reason to say that stars
are more
fundamental than black holes as a matter
of fact we know black holes form when
stars collapse into themselves
um so no I I no no I'm afraid I don't
see love as as fundamental I see
subjectivity phenomenal Consciousness as
fundamental and I would love if love
were fundamental I would love it
um but I I don't see good reasons to
think that it is no why would you love
it if it was fundamental
well because now we would feel all fuzzy
and warm
and protected and safe
um but I don't think there is good
reason to think that I think
what
and now I'm speculating and I'm
speculating without Authority here so
take it with a with a bag of salt I
think what some spiritual teachers I
think what motivates them to say that
love is fundamental is that there is a
phase during meditation or during a
psychedelic experience
you passed through a threshold
right around
the ego dissolution phase when you sort
of shed personal identity
um there's a lot of fear with that but
then you land tend to to land in a place
for a little while where you sort of
remember
and what you remember I can't put in
English I can't put in any there are no
words for what you remember so I can't
say but you remember and that
remembrance feel like a reconnection
with your own umbilical cord with your
own home your own source and it feels
very warm and loving that remembrance
that that reconnection with your roots
but is a transitory phase uh if if you
persist in that then even that is shared
even that feeling of Love fuzzy coziness
you know remembrance back home even that
is shadowy uh as just one more phase of
experience but nothing fundamental and
then you go somewhere else
and I'm not going to talk about that
somewhere else but I can imagine that if
you have not visited the deeper levels
in the Palace of mind you just went one
level lower one or two level lower then
you would say well I found love there so
Love Is Fundamental I I can clearly see
that happening but then I would think
arrogantly maybe that well we just
haven't gone deep enough because below
that there is stuff that you wouldn't
call love
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy